TS spivit is a 10 year old genius living
on a secluded rural Montana Ranch with
his Moody older sister his entomologist
mother and his emotionally distant and
quiet Cowboy father despite the
Primitive standards of his house TS has
become an avid Enthusiast of science
whenever free he often reads books and
tries inventing new things we also
learned that TS had a twin brother
Leighton who died recently in a shooting
accident for which TS blames himself the
tragedy unfolded when he and his brother
were out playing in an old barn on the
property TS reveals that his Cowboy
father was far closer to the extrovert
Layton because the two were similar in
many ways now after the death of his son
the cowboy has difficulty leaving his
room or connecting with ts's
scientifically inclined studies his
mother a PhD scholar has begun studying
insects obsessively she also collects
various specimens to cope with the loss
of her child on the other hand his
sister Gracie is always consumed with
thoughts of beauty pageants and act TS
is often ignored and belittled by the
people around him even at school he is
criticized by his teacher who sees his
intelligence in Innovative thinking as
evidence of arrogance so TS spends most
of his time playing alone making amateur
inventions and walking around the ranch
with the family dog one day he and
Gracie are working with corn kernels on
their porch suddenly their phone rings
and ts's mother picks up the call she is
shocked to hear that someone is looking
for her son soon TS picks up the call
and learns that it is from the renowned
Museum the Smithsonian institution it
turns out that he has won a prestigious
prize for his blueprint of a
magnetically run perpetual motion wheel
now TS is invited to attend the awards
ceremony in Washington DC however the
museum director Miss Gibson who is on
the call believes that TS is actually a
grown man and that the little boy
talking to her is the son of the prize
winner initially TS is reluctant as he
simply can't get out of his house his
Cowboy father would never let his family
step outside the state of Montana let
alone travel to see however since it is
the best shot to achieve something in
his career TS plans to risk it all
finally he decides to run away from home
to receive the prize before leaving he
packs a suitcase and takes one last look
at leighton's old bedroom there's a pile
of Dusty toys and furniture that his
parents are unable to bring themselves
to throw away TS tearfully closes the
door as he still blames himself for his
twin brother's death he then passes by
his sister and father before leaving
however both of them are too wrapped up
in their daily routines to even notice
him this slightly upsets TS as he thinks
to himself no one will notice me even
when I'm gone shortly after the little
boy drags his large suitcase and heads
to the train station being an organized
person he has brought along all his
Essentials like binoculars Compass
winter clothes and so on however at the
train station TS realizes that he is a
bit early so to speed things up he
climbs up a traffic sign and puts the
stop signal on the plan works and just
after a few minutes a train shows up TS
excitedly boards it with his big
suitcase but unfortunately a couple of
authorities notice him realizing that he
doesn't have a ticket they begin chasing
him mercilessly but our little genius
manages to climb up a tower and
successfully makes it to the train below
soon the vehicle begins moving and TS
finally evades the authorities not only
is he a scientist he's also a chef he
knows how to smoke bacon on the way he
makes himself comfortable in one of the
rail cars where he plays and imagines
that Leighton is still there with him
this shows how much he misses his late
brother next the train makes a stop at
Wyoming and the guards at the station
begin to examine the vehicle realizing
this TS hides in an auction show camper
vehicle that's being transported however
the guard is suspicious so he decides to
check the camper vehicle inside we see
that there's a life-sized cardboard
stencil of a family eating dinner TS
pretends to be one of the cardboards so
the guard looking in thinks he's just
part of the art after the narrow Escape
TS realizes that he needs to be careful
so he opts to sleep inside the camper
however when the the train comes to a
halt he decides to head out in search of
food TS soon meets a Drifter named two
clouds and the duo starts chatting in
the next scene two clouds invites the
boy into his trailer and tells him an
inspirational story of how a bird
reached its destination despite facing
many ups and downs the old man then
provides TS with some change so that he
can buy some food for himself next TS
goes to a nearby takeaway shop and
orders hot dogs this is the first time
he is going to eat fast food in his
whole life it turns out his Cowboy
father is so religious that he never
allowed any food products that didn't
come from their farm this makes the hot
dog even more special for TS probably
more disgusting too but right then two
police officers arrive at the scene and
ask the shop owner if she has seen a
missing boy they then bring out a poster
and shockingly the boys revealed to be
none other than TS himself however the
cops are so occupied with their
conversation that they fail to notice
the little boy right next to them after
they are gone T.S nervously talks to the
shop owner and explains that his parents
are dead and that he lives alone to his
luck she doesn't say a word and simply
lets him leave that's nice for ts's sake
but that lady should probably go to jail
while heading back to the train TS
contemplates using a nearby Payphone to
call his family but he can't bring
himself to do it the next day he walks
along the railroad tracks with his
backpack having stored his suitcase in a
nearby electrical grid box at the same
time a mean-spirited policeman pulls up
behind him asking him about his
whereabouts PS lies once again saying
that he is from Chernobyl and also
begins to Converse in a foreign language
unfortunately the policeman catches wind
of his deceit and begins chasing him the
two go back and forth for a while and at
one point TS is almost cornered so he is
forced to climb Atop A separating bridge
where a boat is passing through
unfortunately the move turns out to be a
dangerous one and TS is left hanging
from the bridge this frightens the cop
and he frantically apologizes to the
little boy for chasing him he even
provides instructions on how to climb
back up thankfully TS being an
intelligent boy uses the laws of physics
to his advantage and eventually reaches
safety however during the struggle he
injures his ribs causing him immense
pain to make matters worse his compass
and favorite Sparrow skeleton that he
brought along are also destroyed
heartbroken TS throws both of his
belongings into the river he then heads
to the highway and attempts to hitchhike
a ride almost every vehicle ignores him
but a friendly trucker named Rick stops
and pulls him up it turns out Rick
usually offers rides to people which
becomes evident when he showcases his
collection of photographs with them
there's a red flag if I've ever seen one
later as the two are talking Rick
realizes that the young boy is badly
injured near the chest so he advises TS
to visit a doctor soon but the latter
says he is fine TS is still scared that
he will be discovered by the authorities
and sent back to his family ranch in
Montana after Rick drops him off in
Washington TS finally makes it to the
Smithsonian institution there he is
greeted by two receptionists who don't
believe him to be TS spivit the winner
of the prestigious award nonetheless
they Miss Gibson the director of the
institution some time later she arrives
and gets shocked to see a little boy
claiming to be the famed scientist
however the genius lad proves her wrong
by describing his invention from scratch
he also talks about his various other
scientific modules that he is currently
working on Amazed by his vision and
speaking ability Miss Gibson finally
believes that he is the real TS spivot
as the two get lost in their
conversation TS once again lies that he
is an orphan Miss Gibson who only cares
about his talent immediately buys it
later she takes him to a hospital and
gets him checked Miss Gibson also
insists on being his new Guardian
assuring that she will take care of all
his needs but in reality she simply
wants to bask in his Spotlight TS is too
naive to understand this so he agrees he
then asks her to accompany him to the
conference where he will be given the
prestigious Baird award for his
invention in the next few days Miss
Gibson does take good care of TS but she
also starts becoming possessive one day
she even has his brain examined to see
what's really inside had this young
lad's head once the results are out the
doctor reveals that the boy's brain
functions very normally in fact he is no
different than other children however
this only offends Miss Gibson and she
scolds the doctor calling her
unqualified following this we are taken
to the awards ceremony where Miss Gibson
has TS on her toes she dresses him up
and instructs him to act and behave in
certain ways that are favorable for her
job basically the director is only
trying to gain the Limelight for herself
TS sits at a table alone during the
conference while miss Gibson talks to
other attendants about how she has been
taking care of him ever since he became
an orphan the guests are equally
enthralled and excited to meet a 10 year
old boy who made such a breakthrough
invention in science suddenly the little
boy is swarmed by a crowd of admirers
they begin to congratulate him with big
cheerful Smiles but TS knows better he
thinks that these guests are just faking
it because he knows the exact
mathematical calculation that makes up a
real happy smile in the next scene the
organizer of the show congratulates the
young lad for his Discovery and calls
him over to the stage PS slowly makes it
to the podium but remains silent for a
while he then nervously introduces his
background and extends his gratitude to
the attendees who are present there to
see him once he gets the hang of it TS
becomes more confident and he ends up
talking about his dead brother he
finally reveals how his brother died
because of his mistake it turns out that
on that fateful day the two brothers
were experimenting with a gun inside the
barn TS being a science geek wanted to
test the velocity of a bullet while
Leighton simply wanted to shoot they
agreed to help each other out but at the
last second the gun jammed TS tried to
check it and without pulling the trigger
he ended up shooting his brother killing
him instantly after concluding the story
TS sobbingly admits that nobody ever
talks about Leighton anymore as if he
never even existed even the audience is
brought to Tears by the sad story
surprisingly unbeknownst to TS his
mother is also present in the audience
having driven to Washington to find him
later the boy is prepared to appear in a
sensationalist talk show Miss Gibson who
acts as his representative sits behind
in a guest room and watches the
interview back in the live show the host
initially inquires TS about how his
invention came to be the latter tries to
give some scientific background but he
is always cut short by the host who is
only interested in keeping the show
going the host then begins to slowly
divert the topic to ts's Brother since
it will give the show a lot of trp
however Miss Gibson was aware of this so
she had already advised TS to not delve
into the emotional topic the young boy
does as he is instructed suddenly ts's
mother interrupts the interview and
shocks everyone in particular Miss
Gibson is enraged as she now can't be in
charge of the boy anymore the mother
tearfully apologizes to TS saying she
should have been more present for him
she also tells him that leighton's death
wasn't his fault and hearing this the
little boy finally gets some closure he
then hugs his mother happily and the two
leave the interview however backstage a
drunk Miss Gibson starts hurling
obscenities at the little boy this
infuriates his mother so she punches the
selfish woman and calls her out for
taking advantage of her young son pill
yeah while all of this is happening the
show host continues to go live with his
set members he insists the mother and
son give a little time and continue the
interview from earlier unfortunately for
him ts's Cowboy father arrives on the
scene and knocks him out with a solid
punch after this the family happily
returns home in the final scene in a
monologue TS reveals that his mother
just gave birth to a new baby the young
genius puts his skills to the test and
invites an even better perpetual motion
machine than the last one this machine
is now used to rock his new infant
sibling's cradle on the front porch as
the movie ends ts's sister Gracie is
preparing herself for the upcoming Miss
Montana contest
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching